- Producer Olivia bought a turtle neck,
and I think it's a woman's medium.
I don't know how this is gonna work,
we gonna get through the...
It doesn't even have sleeves.
That's so tight, oh my god.
(superhero music)
(Buzzfeed theme tune)
Today, we're going to make a
young child's dream come true.
- Today, I'm being transformed
into my favorite superhero, Superman.
- Darkwing Duck!
- Batman Beyond.
- Darkwing Duck is the
best superhero ever,
because he is so unique.
- I watched the show a lot as a kid,
the world was so imaginative.
- I've been obsessed with Superman
since I was a little kid.
Who doesn't want to be a guy who can fly,
have super-human strength,
lasers out of your eyes
are you kidding me, you name it,
he can do it, and I want that.
It feels like I have a lot of makeup on.
I am afraid to scratch itches.
- The best part about the
costume is easily the dick bill.
I think my face as a human
is kind of a lackluster,
but if you put a duck bill on this face,
it's gonna bring this
whole thing together.
I'm gonna be all new sorts of handsome.
- The thing about the costume that will
make it feel right, is the cape.
Even as a kid, dressing
up in other costumes,
you put a cape on, and
changes your whole demeanor.
- I remember dressing up as a kid,
and the way you really felt
just so different.
I felt like I really could do anything.
- I was Darkwing Duck before.
Once for Halloween,
and I'm really hoping to beef it back up,
'cause last time
I was dressed up as Darkwing Duck.
This time, I'm going to
become Darkwing Duck.
"I am the terror that flaps in the night,
I am Darkwing Duck!"
Wow, I really am Darkwing Duck!
- Whoa!
- (laughing)
My boobs are so high,
it's ridiculous (laughing).
- This is making me feel
sweaty, and powerful.
Those two usually don't go together,
but this is an instance where they do.
- I knew I was more
handsome with a duck bill.
This is a face that deserves a duck bill.
- I feel very stealthy.
I could fight crime, and rob banks
depending on what mood I'm in.
- There's just such a
rush, there's a power.
- I think the fascination is
they're modern mythology,
they're tales are become American legends,
and it's fascinating, and it's fun,
and it's good versus evil.
It's classic story telling.
Who doesn't love that?
(dramatic superhero music)
(Buzzfeed tune)